you wake up this morning and without
knowing it today is the worst day of
your life on the road what are the
things that people need to be aware of
there's two specific ones that come to
mind one is situation awareness we have
a complete loss of situation awareness
in the world around us because we are
immersed in our phones a shocking
statistic is teenage girls spend
anywhere from three and a half to seven
hours a day on social media texting
especially on your phone is going to
kill you the most the other part of that
is most people die in vehicle accidents
when they over correct if you go off the
right side of the road and you lose
traction the over correction which is a
reaction that's natural to jerk the
steering wheel the opposite direction
you think would self-correct you except
you don't have traction you have a loss
of traction so then when you over
correct the steering wheel and you come
back on the road immediately you gain
traction which slingshots you into
oncoming traffic causing head-on
collisions that's the leading cause of
death how do we fix that and we have
people go through defensive driving
training that one little fix could save
thousands of lives